man muss kein genie sein um jacko diaz
neuen film the sisters brothers ganz
wunderbar zu den rätseln was als
nächstes kommt was ja nicht gefallen
giulia hat ja bisher vor allen dingen
film war gedreht auch dass ein genre das
er wirklich aus dem effeff beherrscht
das ist jetzt was ganz neues und das ist
so überraschend vom ersten bild an nacht
so wahnsinnig viel freude sich
anzugucken interessiert sie das was ist
das das ist eine zahnbürste
eigenschaften die ein westernheld bisher
hatte ergeben sich aus deren aus der
konfrontation mit der natur und aus der
konfrontation mit den fremden
das heißt die umstände und das land
machen ausgehen
der zucker dass diese männer reden und
zwar reden sie eigentlich ununterbrochen
und sie reden nicht nur weiß wetter und
über um welchen pillepalle sondern sie
reden wirklich über wesentliche dinge
mit denen sie sich beschäftigen mit
lebensjahr konsum setzen sie nachdenken
also kleiner würde willst du sie zur
frauen eben eine familie mit ihr gründen
irgend sowas keine ahnung was
interessiert sich das auf einmal so
brennen ich glaube dass gerade über
familie und dem zug zu gucken und
zuzuhören das wirklich eine ganz neue
erfahrung
das weiß ich noch wach dann nachdenklich
die männer sind oder werden gespielt von
john riley und heutigen tags das sind
die beiden brüder ist der nachname ist
natürlich ein witz und ist auch lustig
weil im film sagen sie hier kommen
nächstes jahr sparen
wir haben genug geld um ganz aufzuhören
etwas öfter menschen umzubringen glaube
das ist was den royal auszeichnen er
behandelt immer fantasien und stoffe die
mit großer physischer gewalt einher
gehen und er scheut sich auch nicht die
auf die leinwand zu bringen und trotzdem
an seine filme auch eine gewisse zeit
und das ist ja genau das heißt also wir
sehen uns in zukunft nicht mehr
natürlich werden wir uns noch so wann
immer ich in die stadt komme und einen
neuen hut oder unterwäsche war warum
musst du so unhöflich zu mir sein wozu
wählst du solche worte so ein primitives
niveau der unterhaltung weil du
betrunken ist
aber er bleibt eben jetzt in dem system
bleibt er wirklich im rahmen des tores
des werkes western und zeigt wie
ungeheuer ja den ball da die grenzen
sind ja die einfach nur noch nicht
gesehen wurden aber durchaus den ball
sind das heißt er geht gar nicht über
das genre hinaus aber er lässt eben
seine männer lässt er reden und das
macht ihn und einfach wirklich den
unterschied ums ganze
wir sollten früher oder später also
sagen dass es aufhört
wir müssen den kann man doch am rhein
und was dann
sie werden eben wirklich ausgewachsene
figuren statt nur typen zu sein und auch
das ist natürlich eine wesentliche
veränderungen gegenüber den den
klassischen western von denen er sich
aber eigentlich die wesentlichen szenen
und motive auch leid und bedient
wirklich bis zum ende in einer form wie
das so ist so früher eben der westender
kommt nach hause und die frau steht am
gartentor in der schürze und winkt und
so ähnlich ist nicht ganz so ähnlich ist
es hier eben auch und das ist das
erstaunliche wie viel leben in diesem
sommer eigentlich noch stecken wenn man
es unbedingt wie ja oder ja das macht
und es ist mal eine ganz große
empfehlung
wir hatten einen schönen langen lauf wir
sollten aussteigen
wir könnten zusammen im laden eröffnen
einladen was ist das für ein schwachsinn